hello michigan i'm conan o'brien i was
born
in brookline massachusetts but in my
heart
i've always been a michigander what can
i say
i love my donuts from dillas and my beer
from bells
and because i love michigan i'm urging
all of you
including the yupers to vote in the
upcoming election
voting is a cornerstone of our democracy
if you like democracy but you don't vote
you're not playing euchre with a full
deck it's like saying
i like great wolf lodge but not family
friendly water parks
or i like verners but not ginger ale or
i like islands where cars aren't allowed
and everyone
sells fudge but i don't like mackinac it
just doesn't make sense
so get out and vote because if you don't
you're kind of letting other states that
aren't as awesome as michigan
ohio make decisions about your education
your
water your roads and your jobs
and unlike jim harbaugh voting costs
nothing
it's very effective and it lives up to
the hype
so whether you're in detroit grand
rapids or way up in sheboygan
love the hot dogs it dukes sheboygan
it's important that you vote and as an
honorary mission gender
my vote is going to the guy who'll fix
the potholes around here
if you're not a registered voter in
michigan you've still got time go to
when we all vote dot org by october 19th
and register
hope this face doesn't haunt your dreams
see you at the fleetwood diner
the one in east lansing not the one in
ann arbor